Today, we're going to
show you how to build
one of the coolest looking
fountains I've ever seen.
[Music]
Guys, it's been a while
since we've built
a tabletop fountain,
and I love making
tabletop fountains.
I've got another really cool
one that I'm excited
that I figured out how to build.
This fountain was inspired
by a channel called
Living Positively,
which had a video on this type
of fountain about 10 years ago.
It showed the fountain looking
at a little bit in
what's now considered
pretty low resolution.
It didn't really say
how everything was built.
So I've worked out how to make
that type of fountain,
and we're going
to show you step-by-step
how to build one yourself.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll use a small pump
and a specially shaped nozzle to
get a domed mushroom of water.
We'll then use a water vaporizer
and some colored lights
to kick it up a notch.
First off, we've got our bucket.
This is what our whole fountain
is going to be housed in.
The size can change quite a bit.
This is much taller
than it needs to be.
You really only need
four inches of height.
While this is about the smallest
diameter we can use,
you could have
a much larger diameter,
and there would be
no adverse effects.
The next thing we're going
to need is a pump.
Now, there are lots of types
of waterproof submersible pumps.
This particular pump comes
with an additional piece,
this ring light here,
and you can actually fit this in
between the other pieces.
I don't really like
this ring light.
It has multiple colors
going at once,
and there's no control over it.
It's just not my preference.
Most importantly
for this project,
one of the attachments is this.
It's designed for making sort
of mushroom bubbles of water.
It's pretty neat,
but a very simple idea.
The water flows up
through this tube,
which is just being
held right there,
and you can see with the shape
of this, it all goes flowing,
goes up and out,
hits the edge and just
bubbles over on both sides.
In fact, on all sides,
creating a round bubble.
This piece is held
in place with friction.
You can move it up
and down just by grabbing it
and pulling it up,
or pushing it back down,
and that's going
to change the shape
and the size of your bubble
by a little bit.
Just because you're changing
the pressure of the water,
and how far it has to travel
before it hits
the shape piece of plastic.
This pump comes with
a couple other pieces as well,
and most of these
are just extensions.
So you can choose
how high you want
the mushroom piece to go.
And our bucket here,
we are going to need
a little bit of extra height,
because we're going
to want this to sit well
outside the top of the bucket.
So it's a good thing we've got
these extension pieces.
Let's do a quick test
with some water to make sure
this is fountaining
the way we want it to.
Start out with this test.
We're just gonna
add enough water
that our pump is covered.
We don't need to fill
the bucket all the way.
Now, this pump
on the front, it's adjustable.
If you have it open all the way,
its maximum volume of water.
If we have it closed,
it's only a little bit of water.
We're actually going to start
with it closed about
as much as we can,
and then we'll open it up
because if we put too much,
it's likely just spray
all over the place,
and that's not what
we're going for.
Alright, there we go.
We can see what our fountain
is trying to do here.
We've got the water flowing up
through the fountain,
bubbling out into this cool
round mushroom shape.
We are trying to get
a little bit bigger
of a fountain in it,
so I'm going to reach in,
and I'm going to open
the valve on our fountain
so that it's a...
More water is flowing through.
It's a tricky balance.
That's not bad right there.
I'm liking that pretty well.
When you were measuring this,
one of the interesting things
to take into account is
that this bubble can actually
be filled up with more air,
so it can fluctuate,
especially if there's
any air flow in the area.
So, let's see
if I can blow any in,
and make it a little bit bigger.
[Music]
There we go.
I got it to go so big
that it's actually overflowing.
I can pop the bubble,
and it shrinks back down.
Pretty crazy that
it works that well.
It's actually made such
a complete sheet of water
that it just stops
letting any air out.
Now, we can see
how this is working.
It's pretty cool.
Super smooth, complete bubble
going around there.
Let's turn this off for a bit.
We don't want these cords coming
up out of the top
of our fountain super
visible and everything,
so we're going to do something
similar to what we've done
in the past,
and that's to drill
a couple small holes
into the side of the bucket,
and have the cords
coming out there.
I'm putting mine on the back.
I don't want the handle
to be super prominent.
So I'm going to call
this the back,
and this is where I'm going
to drill holes.
[Music]
This cord is not going to fit
through that hole.
So we're gonna have
to do something
that we've done in the past,
and that's cut the cord off,
and splice it back on.
We've got our cords
through the hole.
This one went to the light.
I don't want the light on this,
so I'm actually going to trim
this cord even shorter,
just to about right there.
First, we need to
make this waterproof.
Our bucket is going
to be full of water.
We don't want it
all leaking right there.
So we're going
to use some hot glue,
and we are going to try
and make a very water
tight seal around this.
We'll use a little bit
of electrical tape to just
hold the smaller wire
that used to go to the light
on to the rest of the cord,
make it a little
less visible and obvious.
To secure down and cover
up the end of this wire
that used to be attached
to the light,
we're just going to use
a little bit of heat shrink.
We're going to put
that down over the cord,
and make sure it overlaps
with the end of the wire,
so there's no exposed metal wire
that we could touch
that has electricity
running through it.
For the rest of this wire,
the main plug
that runs the fountain,
we do want to solder back
together one of the two wires.
However, the other wire,
we're going to leave unsoldered.
And we're going to use
that to add in a little
feed through switched.
That way, we should be able
to turn the fountain on and off
just by flipping a switch,
and without having
to unplug it every time.
[Music]
Excellent.
That's just what we want to see.
Next step, we want to add
a little bit of magic to that,
and for that,
we are using this thing,
which is a water vaporizer.
It's an ultrasonic vaporizer.
This little plate right
here is a piece of ceramic,
and when you turn this thing on,
it vibrates at several
thousand times per second.
They're really interesting.
The way it splashes the water up
out actually just causes
the droplets to break
apart into these tiny
tiny little particles.
It just looks like mist,
and when you put this
under water about an inch and
a half to three inches of water,
it starts putting out vapors.
Crazy, right?
Look at that.
Good amount of mist right there.
That's pure water vapor.
There's nothing else involved.
No chemicals.
No changes in temperature.
Interestingly enough,
if you put your finger
in the path of it,
it actually starts to like heat
up the inside of your hand,
and it hurts a lot.
So be careful
when you're using these things,
because you can
really hurt yourself.
This bucket is going
to be filled almost
all the way with water,
and we're going to use some
of this colored glass to help
disperse the light just overall
make the whole effect nicer,
clean it up,
but we don't want
the glass on top of this.
This needs a clear path
from the ultrasonic plate up
to the top of the water.
And what we're going to use
as a shield is a piece
of this ABS pipe.
We're going to fit this
inside a piece of this pipe,
and then we're just going
to cut about an inch
and a half above that,
and we're going to use
that as a sort of barrier
to keep the glass
from getting in there.
Once again, we've got chords
that we need to hide.
In this case,
we have a cord
that we want to come out
the side of the PVC pipe,
and then we're going to want to
come out the side of the bucket.
To allow the cord to hang
down right where we want it,
we're going to use a saw
to just cut a straight line down
to about the midpoint,
so we can have it turn
and head right out.
[Music]
Now, we're going to use just
a little bit of hot glue
to hold this in place.
So it's attached to our pipe,
and not just free
floating around in there.
This gap at the bottom
is probably enough
that it would keep a constant
flow of water into there,
along with the slit on the side,
but just to be sure,
let's drill a couple
holes into it.
That should do it right there.
Water can easily get in,
and it has a clear path
to shoot its water out the top.
Let's give it a test.
In fact, working great.
Just what we want to see.
We're going to want this set
up so the black pipe is
just at the surface
of our water level,
and so, we can kind of choose
about where we want that to be.
I want it quite close
to the top of our,
bucket but not all
the way there,
and then with the cord,
same as last time,
we're going to want to attach it
into the side of the bucket.
Now, this chord is a little
bit different than most.
It actually comes apart
so there's a second
portion of it.
Maybe, it's designed
to be a plug.
Maybe it's just designed
to hold everything in place.
But if we use the right
size of drill bit,
you actually might be able
to use that as a plug right
into the side of our bucket.
Well, our plug sort
of fits into our whole,
but because our drill bit
didn't cut a superfine
clean edge on it,
we're going to want to stop
that up with a little
bit more hot glue.
Just to make
sure it's watertight.
Let's add a switch
into our ultrasonic
vaporizer as well.
[Music]
Just what we want to see.
Let's start adding some
of our glass rocks down in here.
Those are going to do
a few different things.
One, they're just going to add
a nice look to the whole thing.
We're going to be adding
some waterproof LED remote
controlled lights inside there.
It's going to do a really
good job of diffusing
that light all over,
and holding them up.
And three, to lift up
the ultrasonic vaporizer
a little bit so it's higher,
and it's going to be sitting
on top of some of the rocks.
[Music]
Oh, I like that.
Okay.
Well, I'm going
to try turning it on,
but we'll see
where it is right now.
[Music]
We may have lucked out.
All the plastic pieces
that fit together adding
up to make the extension
for this have a little bit
of play in them.
So if we aren't quite centered,
we can usually just
push it a little bit.
Let's try turning on the fog.
[Music]
This is what looks so good.
We've now got a little bubble
that's just full of vapor,
like all the time.
It's just--
Oh, it's magical.
Then, you can,
you can poke it,
and the vapor just all leaks
out all of a sudden.
It seriously just
like otherworldly,
like this doesn't look
like a thing
that you can just have,
just full of smoke and stuff,
but it works so well.
I love this thing.
[Music]
There we have it.
What I think really is probably
the coolest looking fountain
that we've ever
built in the show.
I love the way this looks.
It's seriously just like
some weird alien creature.
When it fills with mist,
and then you can like
let the mist out,
being able to blow it
up and pop it again.
Not that hard to build.
Honestly, you can do this whole
thing in an hour easily.
There are links
in the description
for where to buy the pump
and the ultrasonic vaporizer.
As for the bucket and glass,
you don't have to use glass,
that's just what we use
because we had it available.
Whatever you want to do,
lots of variety.
I actually probably
would recommend a slightly
larger container.
Maybe something,
you know planter that's
about that wide across,
and the reason for that is
that it doesn't splash
or leak too much
when it's just sitting here,
but when you turn it on and off,
it does have a tendency to
splash a little bit like this.
Got out on the sides there.
And then turning it on
is even more splashy.
When it first kicks in,
it doesn't always kick
in a nice even circle at first.
So I used a little bucket
because I like the compact look.
It all just stays together.
However, this does need
to be mounted outside as it is,
because otherwise,
we're just going to get water
all over every time
I turn it on and off.
Love this project.
This is a seriously
fun-looking fountain.
I am super happy with
how it turned out.
Thanks again to the channel
Living Positively for the idea
for this fountain.
It's really cool,
and your channel is
the only place I've seen it
before building it in real life.
So I'm really glad
it worked out.
Guys, that's not all.
We've got more for you to see.
The box at the top takes you
to our last video,
you should go check that out.
The other box shows you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
And of course,
if you hit this bomb in the middle,
you'll be subscribed
to the channel, so you
never miss out on a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.